[inaudible]
joining me today as a biologist,
a former professor at evergreen state
who is now a professor in exile Bret
Weinstein.
And welcome back to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me back on
professor and exile life friend.
That's what it says on your Twitter bio,
which means it's your most
defining characteristic right now.
That has become the the tenor of my life.
All right,
so I went into the Rubin report archives.
They're very much like the Jedi archives.
I went into the Ruben report archives
this morning that you were on this show
originally on May 30th, 2017. So
that's about a year and a half ago.
It was just as the Evergreen
Brouhaha was beginning.
You, you still were
employed at the time, uh,
which probably seems like a lifetime ago.
Um,
so I think first maybe we should just
play a little catch up from then.
I just to be clear, you, you have
been on the show one since then.
You are on with your brother Eric.
And we did a little bit about
evergreen in your life, but I saw,
I've thought first let's just do catch
up on, on what happened, where you're at,
where you're going,
and then we're going to do sort of new
territory and we're going to cover a
lotta biology and all that.
Great.
So May 30th of 2017 would be
exactly one week into the riots.
The protests at my classroom that became
relatively famous happened on May 23rd
so one weekend I was sitting in this chair
and that feels like a lifetime ago,
doesn't it?
I mean it feels like it for me and
I think less has happened to me,
although it's been a pretty
busy year and a half.
The transformation of my life and
Heather's life in that period has been so
dramatic that it's hard to even relate.
You know?
I've never had so much happen in a year.
Yeah. So, okay. So for people that
don't know anything about the story,
and I suspect there's very few
watching this at the moment,
can you give me like the
92nd recap of what happened?
So can that be done in 90 seconds?
Let's see.
It can be done with with carnage.
I'll say I feared this question more
than any other because there's so much
detail in the story. It can't
be covered properly. Give,
give a cliff notes version
that basically as an explainer,
equity and inclusion movement got started
on my campus as it is on virtually
every campus.
And the new president of
Evergreen threw fuel on the fire.
He used the division over that issue
to accomplish things he could not have
accomplished otherwise.
I tried to block his moves to dismantle
the excellent part of Evergreen's
teaching model, which Heather
and I were using to full effect.
And I became effectively enemy number one
of this equity and inclusion movement.
They arranged a protest at my classroom.
Very dramatic.
50 students showed up
demanding my resignation.
Not a single one of them was a
student I had ever encountered. Um,
but in any case,
they made a terrible error.
They filmed their confrontation with me.
They uploaded it.
I now know to Facebook somebody
else in the public, uh,
picked those videos up and broadcast
them in the world, watched me,
tried to reason with them.
And uh,
that set things in motion where evergreen
started using me as an excuse for its
problems.
It blamed me for what happened there
for the drop off in enrollment for all
sorts of things.
And uh,
I started engaging with the public about
what was taking place at Evergreen, uh,
issues of freedom of expression,
free inquiry on college campuses and
increasingly a evolutionary biology,
which, you know, people, uh,
did not initially really understand that
that was the focus that I had not uh,
freedom of speech issues.
Now increasingly that's what
people want to talk to me about,
although we going to get to plenty of
that because I know that's what you're,
your real focus and passion is.
And it's sort of funny that now
you've been thrust into this. Um,
but in effect you were protesting
putting racist policies on campus.
Is that fair to say? Yes, and
this is one of the, I think,
hardest lessons for people to learn.
People,
good people get the idea that you can
spot the right side by certain heuristics.
And you know,
there's been a historical fact of
oppressed people tending to be people of
color,
et cetera.
And so people have gotten lazy about
recognizing who's in the right.
If you follow a principle to its
logical conclusions. In other words,
if you're against segregation,
for example, as I am,
then when the segregationists are telling
white people to leave campus or asking
them to leave campus, then you are
committed to standing against segregation.
And when you do stand against segregation,
the world goes crazy
because people who are, um,
being lazy about recognizing which side
is defending the principle that they,
they subscribe to, uh, they fall out
in the wrong place. And so anyway,
yes, it is your principles and adherence
to them that gets you in trouble. Yeah.
Okay.
So you then show up in this studio a
week after this whole thing goes down.
It was your first public
interview about any of this.
What did you think at the time was
going to happen by talking about this
publicly or, or what was your hope at
least by talking about this publicly?
Well,
you know,
initially my hope was to expose the
foolishness at evergreen and save the
college from its own
worst instincts because
your audience may not care
terribly deeply about this,
but for a small number of people,
for 4,000 students at a time,
Evergreen was actually a wonderful
experiment in which it was possible for
people who hadn't had tremendous,
uh,
educational advantages before they got
to college to have an experience that
couldn't be reproduced anywhere else.
Evergreens model was so unique that if
you ended up in the right classrooms with
professors who really cared, it was,
it was like no other place. And,
and you were given incredible,
uh,
freedom as a professor to do what
you wanted with these kids. Right.
I believe that the position that Heather
and I had was the freest academic
position in the country
and maybe on earth. Wow.
I mean, really more freedom than a
tenured professor at Harvard has.
And that was, let's be honest, it
was both a blessing and a curse.
If you decided to use
that freedom for good,
if you decided to figure out how to
innovate structures that didn't exist
anywhere else, you could do it
and nobody could tell you not to.
On the other hand, if you
decided to, uh, you know,
take the rest of your career off and
you know, teach with one hand while you,
you know, dealt with your hobbies,
you could also get away with murder.
And so that happened as well. And
you know, there was a tension every,
every good professor at evergreen grumbles
about the fact that there are a large
number of people who,
uh,
are holding positions there that they
don't really value. And you know, the,
the phrase that we,
that we typically used in private on
the faculty was that Evergreen paid in
freedom, which meant, um,
that it didn't pay well.
It wasn't a good paying job,
but the ability to have a blank
canvas and decide how you were,
you know,
what you wanted to teach and in what way,
and to innovate new mechanisms and take
students off campus for a week or two or
10.
Um,
that freedom was a very
valuable commodity,
that Evergreen undervalued
the whole time it should have.
It should have leveled with people that
it was hiring and it should have said,
look,
this job is not going to make you wealthy,
but it can make you very happy if you
have the temperament that really wants to
figure out what's possible.
So as this was unfolding and now you went
public and you also did Rogan and you
were on Tucker Carlson where you said,
I'm deeply progressive because suddenly
you were sort of getting crap from your
side, so to speak, and you were getting
embraced by perhaps a different side.
And I do want to get a little more into
that now because it shows what a sort of
crazy realignment politically
we've had these days. Um,
were you shocked how deep it
went? So you went public, you are,
you are giving the facts,
you were exposing sort of the corruption
and how it went all the way up to the
administration and all that.
I think from that first interview we did,
I think you thought that there would
be a course correction in your,
or at least there was a chance for a
course correction and at least the way I
read the last year,
at no point was there a slow down or any
reflection from the administration and
the rest of it,
they just went in on it.
Yes.
I am completely shocked by the fact
that the world's recognition of just how
awful things were at evergreen did not
force an acknowledgement that something
was wrong.
So I would not have been surprised if
evergreen had backed off cynically if they
had privately said, actually we were on
the right track, we were misportrayed and,
but we nonetheless have to acknowledge
what the world is saying to us.
The fact that that did not happen at all
still shocks me and I can't explain it
because you have a president who
is widely understood to be a,
is there a polite word for bonds?
He's bonkers. He's is one of my favorite
words. Yeah. I like bananas too,
but bonkers whackadoodles Yang. But in
any case, we have a president who was,
I mean, look, he's the mad king, right?
He's the mad king and you've got a whole
bunch of people standing around, um,
accepting his authority when
in fact he's an outsider,
is understanding of the college,
uh,
or his plans for the college
are completely inconsistent
with the values that
the college was founded on.
Yeah.
And where are they really
accepting as Athari actually,
because there are moments in,
in the chaos of this that these videos
are posted where he can't even leave to
go to the bathroom. And it's like he
was also a hostage in this, in his own,
maybe his own like perverted
dream or something.
You know what I mean?
He was,
um, both puppet and puppeteer.
Yeah. Okay. Um, and so the thing is,
yes,
he is held hostage in those things,
but I believe he's a willing hostage in
the sense that he's trying to accomplish
something and you know, look,
it tells the whole tail.
Once you say what we are
doing is about equity,
there is a whole swath of people that
cannot figure out how they would object no
matter what it is that you say next,
no matter what your plan is.
If you've said that it is for
the purpose of racial equity,
then a whole section of the
population will just fall in lockstep.
What is that? What is that
psychologically do you think? Oh,
I know because I think we're
seeing this everywhere now.
This is not just something that's
happening at universities anymore.
This is happening all over
society. I wish I could. I could
say that it is an error in cognition
that people are seeing it incorrectly.
What I know for sure now as well as
anybody on earth is that the part of
people's minds that drives them
in the direction of silence,
of self editing,
of all of these things is
actually accurately perceiving
a threat that it cannot
manage. Now, I'm not looking for sympathy.
I do not have my job anymore.
And I miss it. It was a great,
however, I've landed on my feet, I'm, I
wouldn't trade my position for any other.
I like where I am. However, first of all,
there's not an infinite number
of those positions in the world.
So most people who are looking at
some sort of an equity and inclusion
juggernaut who are thinking,
should I stand up,
actually have to ask themselves
what happens if I do? Um,
do I have an economic plan
B for my family? Right?
Anybody who doesn't have an economic plan
B for their family. And I have to say,
as much as I would like evergreen to
be a place in which all the faculty had
enough skills that they
could go do something else.
If they have to, they don't.
Right? They can't easily move to another
college because the way they teach at
Evergreen doesn't, uh, create a CV that
will get you hired elsewhere easily. Um,
and so I think lots of people
are looking ahead and saying,
if I stand up and I say the
right thing now, what, what will,
what will become of me? And the
problem, the place where I, you know,
I have sympathy for anybody who sees that
and says, look, I don't have a plan B.
I don't know what to do.
Where I lose sympathy with them is when
they then having made that calculation,
rationalize what they are saying
and they join, not reluctantly,
but they become enthusiastic allies
of this movement in order to,
uh, basically they sell
the rest of us out. Right.
And in a weird way,
they almost have to do that
psychologically to live
with themselves. Right.
I mean,
otherwise you realize that mean
then you are a sellout in the,
you know, it, it's harsh, but it's
true. But what I'm so fat, why?
The reason I'm so fascinated
with this is because as you know,
I've been on tour with Peterson for the
last couple months and I think this is
the number one question that we get asked.
People want to speak up and they
are afraid of losing their jobs.
And I think that's why your
story resonated with so
many people because people
were looking at you and going,
well, it's pretty freaking obvious.
This guy is not a racist. He's not
a hater. He's a self identified,
left d and progressive
and all of these things.
And somehow he stood up to the monster.
And I think the fact that you're
still here and you're, you're at,
you're not employed at the moment.
And I W I do want to discuss
that a little bit too,
but the fact that you're still here,
you're alive,
you're still willing to
talk about these things.
I think that's the type of courage that
people are looking for at the moment.
Well, you know, I do.
So I have to say for I know a year now,
uh,
I have had these interactions,
you know,
a couple of times a day somebody will
come up to me on the street and unless I'm
in Olympia, it's always
nice. People have people,
even sons beard,
they're still coming up to actually that
has reduced that I think are not quite
sure. Yeah. There is that who I think
it is or is that Eric or is it provided?
I don't know. But you go buzz cut and,
and then you're Scott free then. Oh Man,
I'd be, yeah, I could go on the
Lam. They'd never find me. Yeah. Um,
but
the thing is the,
it raises questions.
The stuff that people say to me about
what they see on the outside, you know,
I get to compare that to what
the experience was on the inside.
And so I've done a lot of thinking
about what it is, is, you know,
is there some reason that that I stood
up when others didn't. And I think,
you know, it comes down to something
simple, which, you know, I'll just,
I'll just put it out there.
I think people are rationalizing their
acceptance of this nonsense movement in
order to sleep.
And for some reason that particular
switch works the opposite way from me.
If I heard myself rationalizing
that I would not be able to sleep.
So in order to sleep I had
to stand up and you know,
I'm lucky, I have really good friends.
I have a wonderful brother who was,
you know, friends with you and
that put us in contact and uh,
I have something else to talk about.
Evolutionary biology is
fascinating to people.
They don't know how to think
about it. And there, you know,
just as my students where they're very
interested to hear what I have to say on
the subject.
So that means somehow,
even though I couldn't see it
exactly on May 23rd of 2017,
there was a path forward
for me, which, you know,
it could come crashing down tomorrow,
but so far it looks good and I,
I regret nothing.
Is there an evolutionary explanation
to that type of person that either can
sleep or cannot sleep?
Because you know,
people come up to all of us all the time.
Now and they say,
I wish I could speak up. I don't want
to lose my job. My wife's pissed at me.
I mean all of these things.
And they're literally,
sometimes I'm talking to people one on
one and they're whispering, I mean this,
this,
this layer of fear is seriously real
and it is sitting on top of people.
So is there an evolutionary explanation
why at the moment it seems that a very
small amount of people are doing
it? Absolutely. And for me,
just quickly,
I would just say for me it's like,
I don't know if it's about sleeping,
I just,
I just feel like I'm doing what's right.
That's it. It's actually not more,
uh,
you know,
it's not more a confusing or
needs more of an explanation
and then that, that's just
what I'm doing. Um, yeah,
there are two things to say on this front.
One,
so I know we're going to talk more about
evolutionary theory later on, but yeah,
there is a way in which evolutionary
theory stalled 30 years ago and I don't
believe that the explanation that you're
looking for is on the table in the way
that you know any evolutionists
that you asked, but say, Oh yeah,
the explanation is over here,
but I do believe we can see what it is.
There are a lot of adaptations that
do not map well onto the individual.
If you look at the individual and you say,
well,
why would the person behave this way?
It seems paradoxical sometimes if
you look at something larger than the
individual and it's not the group.
This is the thing.
We've been caught in this argument about
group selection since the 60s and or
actually even earlier, but that's
where it began to come to a head.
If you look at the lineage that is to say
a population of people who are related
now talking about ancestral
ancestral populations,
there are many,
uh,
characteristics that have value
for the lineage moving forward,
that are hard to understand from the point
of view of the individual and many of
the things that we have a
really hard time explaining,
including things like
homosexuality and religion. Um,
many of these things are adaptations
that exist at that slightly higher level.
And so what I would say is an individual
who can't sleep if they're not doing
the right thing or if they hear themselves
rationalizing that individual is not
well suited to certain jobs.
Um,
but they're very well
suited to other jobs.
And the idea that a population
has an emergent nature and that,
you know, a division of
labor between, you know,
I'm not telling you that not
rationalizing is the way we should all be.
It may well be that we need certain
people who are very good at carefully
rationalizing certain things in
order to get jobs done. I mean,
I would imagine if you
are in the military,
if you were in a position
of command in the military,
that there are certain things that you
have to rationalize in order to win the
war. Now, I'm not saying
I don't like war. Uh,
I'm not saying that, you
know, every war should be one.
You know, you shouldn't enter into
a war that, uh, isn't justified.
But once you've entered into it,
the goal is justified.
Maybe you have to rationalize
certain things. You know,
you move troops over here in order
to protect something over there.
Well, what are you doing to these people?
You may be sending them to their deaths.
So, you know, I even talking
about it makes it makes me
uncomfortable because, uh,
it's not something I would be good at.
But the point is,
when you look at the population and the
fact is the populations that we have
alive on earth today are all winners,
right? These are the winners.
Irrespective of how you got here.
You're respective of how, uh,
oppressed your population
looks in relation to other,
somehow you made it to the
president. You're a winner. Um,
those winning populations
had many characteristics
within them and they knew how
to call upon these people and you know,
sideline those people and then switch
it up at the point you arrive somewhere
else. We're different skills are
necessary. So, um, in essence, yeah,
I think there's a very simple evolutionary
explanation and some of us have
certain skills,
other people have other skills.
And the real trick is can you figure
out the switching mechanism that decides
what to call on?
At what moment?
That seems to be the key part of
this, right? I mean, that's it.
It's like some people are going to do it.
Some people,
some people know they should
do it and won't do it.
Some people probably shouldn't do it
and do, do it and everything in between.
Well,
you know, you probably have
this experience too, but when I,
when people come up to
me and they talk to me,
there's just a couple of different
styles of conversation that unfold. Um,
you know, there's lots of
people who want to, you know,
apologize for what happened to me,
which I always find that odd. You know,
unless they were there in the room, right.
Unless it was them just never knows.
But I'm guessing those people have nothing
about him that you never contacted me.
But you know, some people want
to apologize, some people,
you know,
I want to thank me and some people,
there's this one thread which is I'm
facing something like this too. Yeah.
Can you give me some advice?
And you know,
I always say the same sort of thing
to them and it throws them, you know,
I always say, look, it's not safe.
You have to think very carefully about
what you're doing and don't kid yourself
about what you're signing up
for and you know, you can,
you just watch in their eyes as they,
um,
grapple with the fact that they
didn't get what they wanted from me,
what they want it to be told. They wanted
somebody to egg them on and say, do it.
It's the right thing. It'll work out. And
you tell them, oh, it may not work out.
And you know,
there's a moment of heartbreak,
but my hope is that the people who should
do it have to go through that little
heartbreak in order to
get to the other side.
And so among my various,
uh,
jobs at the moment is to show
people the abyss and just say,
look, is this the abyss
you want to jump? If it is,
nobody can tell you that, but
you, I certainly can. Yeah.
It would be irresponsible of me to tell
people to do something like what I did.
Because you could get,
you could get maimed.
Yeah. And in a way it's, it's sort
of the shows that I'm most proud of.
Here are the ones where I was able
to facilitate a little bit of that.
So it's sitting down with you.
It's sitting down with Lindsay Shepherd
who went through something very similar
and sitting down with James Damore,
these people who did not ask to,
to be heroes, who even if I say the word
hero, I can see you're uncomfortable.
You know what I mean?
Like the people that didn't want this,
but somehow it got thrust upon them.
And then,
and then they got there and then hopefully
I was able to amplify that a little
bit, which then spreads that out
to all sorts of other people,
which is pretty cool. So let's, let's,
I know I don't want to do this for
obviously the entire interview,
so let's just catch up on a couple
of things. What we'll do a bit more.
So there's one
thing that is, and I believe
there's a little caveat to it.
If you do it and you'd do it for
the right reasons, in other words,
you could do it cynically.
You could stand up against one of these
things in order to see if you couldn't
get famous or something. People
will see through that, right?
Especially the people who've gone
ahead down this road because they know
something about it. Um, but if
you do it for the right reasons,
if you're really trying to advance
the ball to challenge a bad narrative,
the people who have gone through
this recognize and you know,
it won't feed you,
but it is very reassuring to
discover other people who see a,
the corrupt narrative who understand
what happens when you challenge it. Um,
so anyway, if, if you're hungry
to meet other people like that,
uh, standing up, you know,
you got to figure out what they're
going to do to feed yourself,
but it does put you in contact with lots
of people who, uh, are very worthwhile.
Yeah. It's so interesting because
again, after being with Peterson,
it's like people say to him, you
know, I want to get a new job.
Should I just quit my job tomorrow?
And it's like you have to seriously
think about what your options are.
You may hate your job, but doesn't
mean you can leave tomorrow. Right?
You got to think about
all of this seriously.
And I think that that is the key here.
So I'm curious how much of this has
shifted what you think politically,
because you do talk about politics now.
And I know when I had you in there for
the first time, I think I said to you,
we'll revisit this question because
I thought, here's a guy that's that.
I come from a very
similar political places,
him as a progressive and all
of these things. And now I
see, you know, as you know,
I consider myself a classical liberal
and I, and I love libertarian ideas.
Obviously we just did stand up
together last night in Bray California.
You and your brother joined me on stage
for the second half and it was mostly a
conservative crowd.
There were some Trump people,
there were some lefties and some liberals,
but you know,
mostly conservatives
and they love you guys.
And yet you both still identify
as lefties and the whole thing.
And I wonder now,
a year and a half later,
are you shocked at that,
that you are now really liked by people
that perhaps you thought were your yogic
opponents and now you're sort of on the
outs with the people that you used to be
allies with? Okay, that's, that's a
good question. I get one every episode.
Um,
I am
hardened and flabbergasted by
what I encounter on the center.
Right.
You know,
this is not the Republican party
that I remember from my youth.
This is a very different entity and I
think it has a lot of refugees who had
been driven out of other places and
they've grouped there because I don't,
because, because something over
there is making sense to them.
Well, as you said to me
the first time we met Dave,
you have PTSD for vehicle from
the, yeah. I must say we should,
we should return to this,
but I, I, uh, was very
heartened to hear you bring that up.
Um, during your episode with, uh,
with Ben Shapiro and Eric
and, and Jordan, you, uh,
you went through a cool exercise,
which I think deserves a place. Um,
with steel manning and your exercise I
think was something like where is some
place that you suspect your own thinking
might be incorrect and you brought up
political PTSD as a place
to pay attention to.
But let's just say I am shocked that uh,
the center right seems to be,
you know,
it has protective custody of liberty and
free speech and science of all things.
I mean,
how the heck did the center right ended
up ended up having custody of these
things which are traditionally things
that the writers is uneasy about on the
left, uh, has, has
defended. But nonetheless,
the people who value
them are where they are.
I think they do have something wrong.
You, your, your initial question was,
has this changed my political view?
And I think one of the everybody
said it would. And I, you know, I,
I believe I am being honest with myself
when I say really hasn't changed my view
of what is true
politically much if at all.
I think because what I believe is true
isn't predicated on anything social.
Right?
In other words,
these are conclusions that I reached
through game theory and evolutionary
thinking and observation of the political
landscape. They're not things, you know,
it wasn't that I went to a dinner party
and had a good time and fell in with
their political ideas. Right? So it's
not, you know, the fact that I am not,
um,
welcomed in certain quadrants of the left,
it doesn't change anything about
what's true at all. Right. It can't.
So I, I understand that, but
at the same time, I mean,
you can go to, I've done public
events with you that are usually,
we're usually invited by libertarian
organizations. Um, we've done some iron,
ran things together and,
and a couple of other things.
And I think everything that we've done
publicly and when you joined me for stand
up, the crowds all basically seem to
be on the right, as you're saying,
this sort of new, this new center, right.
That maybe needs a better phrase
than that concenter rights.
It needs something sexier than
that per se. Um, but I mean,
have you been invited anywhere by
progressive's to tell your story or to get
some comradery or empathy or sympathy
or Kudos or anything other than GFE very
occasionally
and only slightly. I mean,
the, the asymmetry is amazing.
And I must say one of the most interesting
things to me about the early phase
of, um, you know,
just public part of my life
is that initially there
was just this overwhelming,
uh, uh, message that came back at me.
You are a conservative or welcome to
conservatism or something like that.
And to the dark side I think is
what they usually do. Say that.
And then at the point that,
uh,
the phrase IDW showed up on the landscape,
then there was this point about,
oh, the IDW is, uh, you know,
right wing movement or
something like that.
And so there's a trajectory there.
There's something,
we track immediate effects pretty well
as people we can observe them and detect
them.
There's often a slower pattern
that is harder for us to see.
And so just by analogy, I find this
as true with healing, you know,
just physical healing. If you do
damage to your knee, for example,
there's a one month healing trajectory,
but there's also a one year and a five
year trajectory and they're much harder
to spot. Um, so anyway, the,
the interesting thing is the challenge
of you're on the right or now,
surely you will be moving to the right.
You know,
that was just an overwhelming
message that came back. Um, but the
ability to talk back to that
message and say, actually, no,
still on the left, actually part of a
left, you don't even remember exists.
And one of my fears is that all of the
stuff that the left was correct about is
not getting properly credited now.
So to the extent,
I don't know if people have seen this,
a hidden tribes,
a report that came out maybe a month
ago now that says that there's this vast
Alsace, yeah, 80% in the middle
of do agree on, you know,
the desirability of a fair society that
doesn't burden one population in order
to enrich another. And you
know, that we basically share
that basically it's only 8% actually
that buy into this hyper political
correctness and the, and the rest of that,
it's a tiny fringe, the authoritarian
left and it's a tiny fringe on the,
you know, the white nationalists,
right. And the rest of us in the middle,
you know, we're not in perfect agreement,
we don't agree on the
order of the priorities,
but we do agree basically on what
a good society would function like.
And that a lot of the
gains, I mean, you know,
the ability to be gay and out and
function in society without that being a
tremendous obstacle that that's
something that, you know,
the left deserves credit for
racial equality. You know,
equity is a different beast
by virtue of the new, uh,
I hesitate to even call it at definition
because it's not a definition in the
standard sense,
but it quality.
These are traditional left
values and we were right about.
And so the fact that these things are
now no longer controversial that belongs
in the discussion to the left
has been right about some stuff.
It's also been wrong about some stuff
and the right has been right about some
stuff and it's been wrong about some stuff
and it is time for that conversation.
Absolutely. And that's why I
don't denigrate what it was.
I am upset with what it is and perhaps
guys like you and your brother and Sam,
some people that still identify as left,
these will be able to do a reclamation
project that I just don't see anymore.
I see sort of more that this thing
needs to burn. So out of the ashes,
the Phoenix can rise. That's just
maybe a little bit of a tactical thing,
but let's just jump back to an
evolutionary explanation for some of this.
So I asked you about why some people can
do this from an evolution evolutionary
perspective, why some people are able
to step up and some people aren't.
What about,
what's the evolutionary
explanation for why this,
let's say 8% very loud,
but small group of people feel the
need to purge everyone. Is there,
is there an evolutionary,
because that seems it would be
almost counter to evolution.
You'd want to have more commonalities
with people and bring in a big tent.
But what I see them consistently doing is
just getting rid of everybody who dare,
you know, talk back to the,
to the God. Well, you know, I,
I wish I had known this was gonna come
up cause I would have looked it up,
but there was, uh, there
was, uh, put me on the spot,
got a report that emerged.
Maybe it was six or eight months
ago that I don't, you know,
I haven't looked into it and it's
not my area of specialty, but, uh,
it sounded right to me. And what it
said was that there is a particular,
um,
there's a particular personality trait,
authoritarianism that isn't ideological.
It doesn't really care
whether it's, uh, you know,
defending fascism or communism,
um, what it wants to do,
his boss,
people around.
And that essentially what's confusing
to people is that at the moment,
these dyed in the wool authoritarians
are concentrated over on the left and
they're saying stuff that sounds
nominally like leftist stuff, but that,
you know,
we're the winds to shift
and the authoritarians have
the moment to be over on
the right they be there. And so, uh, that,
that makes sense to me.
And what I would like people,
yourself included to consider is that
there is almost no point in engaging those
people,
right?
This question of the importance
of liberty is settled, right?
The 80% of us in the middle all get
the fringe on the far left
and the far right are,
I don't want to say safe to ignore
because they can always rise up and become
important as the one on the
left is doing. Um, however,
that's not where the game is.
The game is all of the people who can't
figure out how to escape from the stigma
at all.
That is driving civilizations.
So all of the people who are falling
in line with what's going on on the
authoritarian left,
those are the people to reach.
And what you raise about,
you know,
let's say the audience last night
at the comedy club and you know,
this is reliable,
this was the second one I with you.
It was exactly the same the first time.
The thing that is so heartening is,
you know,
I can come into a room and you're right,
that room last night must've
been 95% right of center.
Yeah.
And first thing you tell them is here's a,
a progressive, I'm, I tell them
I'm a radical, right? Yeah.
It doesn't dampen their
enthusiasm one bit. In fact, it,
they're thrilled to discover that things
are not so bleak and that there is
somebody on the other side of this thing
who still talking reasonably and can
hear them and can see them and doesn't
think that they're racist and out of
control. And so anyway, you know,
I know I take a lot of flack for,
you know,
interacting with the right and I am not
listening to that flack because it is
the best thing we can do is
to engage and uh, you know,
when you spot the humanity of
the people on the other side,
then to the extent that we differ
over something, we can talk about it.
All right. Well we could keep
going down this Pandora's box of,
of lunacy related to everything that
you've been through. But let's do,
let's just catch it up to where we are
now and we can start looking at the
future a little bit. So
you and your wife, Heather,
who you referenced how they're high end,
who's been on the show,
who's a brilliant professor as
well and, and, and has that,
that brave evolutionary
tick that you have to,
how'd you end up marrying a woman that
was going to have the same evolutionary
tickets? You, that's pretty good. Uh,
you really want to know the answer. Yeah,
I'm Heather and I, we were not going out,
but we were friends in
high school and you know,
I don't know that others will
understand the, the phrase,
but the one that runs in my head is
somebody goes to high school with the girl
you should marry and it might be you.
Right. So anyway, in my case, you know,
I don't know how because you
know, I was, I was a confused kid.
Like every other kid that age,
there was something about her
that seemed so very right.
And I have to say,
um,
I was right about that
best decision I ever made.
Was she ever pissed at you during this
because you sort of thrust her in the
spotlight too. And the fact
is both of you left your jobs,
you got a $500,000 settlement
for two tenured positions,
which to some people that out if I
hundred thousand dollars, I was like, oh,
that sounds like a lot of money.
But, but this is your life's work.
You and your wife, you've since relocated
your family and your two kids. Um,
so this is, this is massive. 500 grand
in the scheme of that is not a lot.
But was she ever sure,
uh, bothered or, or hesitant
by what you were doing?
Cause she didn't go public about
this until a bit after. Um,
she was never pissed.
Not for a minute.
She and I were in complete agreement.
We saw the same thing
unfolded evergreen. The, uh,
the nature of our teaching at Evergreen
was kind of interesting in the sense we
had like a little undeclared graduate
program and evolutionary biology where we
couldn't award you a master's degree,
but if you were interested in evolutionary
biology and many people didn't know
they were,
but they would take my program and uh,
then I would sort of nudge them
over towards Heather's program.
So we had students bouncing back and forth
and we had a community of people that
were, um, in our circle.
So the basic point is that creates a,
a,
an opportunity for every night at dinner.
Heather and I would compare notes,
what we were seeing at the college and
all of these things talk about, you know,
students, you know, what
the student's blind spot is,
what they do particularly well.
And as this unfolded,
Heather and I saw the identical picture,
or maybe the way to say it is the picture
of what was happening emerged between
us as we discussed it. And she
was, let's put it this way,
what put me in the bullseye
was the emails that I wrote.
And the thing is I said
in faculty meetings,
I never wrote an email that Heather didn't
look at first and tell me it's ready.
Um, and frankly there were a lot of emails
that I didn't send and if I made one
error, I believe I should have
sent every one of them, right.
Because what they do is they leave a,
a historical record of
what is taking place.
So the descent was in retrospect, very
clear as you went back through the emails.
Um, but anyway, yeah, Heather, Heather
was in complete agreement the whole time.
And I think,
uh,
the confrontation was less in keeping
with her personality traits than mine,
but in terms of her commitment and
her belief in what we were doing,
it was a team effort.
There's a lesson in
marriage right there at,
there's probably many lessons in
marriage. Okay. Yeah. All right,
so let's just get to where you are now.
You guys have left Washington.
Neither one of you are
teaching at the moment.
You're trying to figure out what your
future is. I assume the same with Heather.
What does that like,
number one and number two,
I think a lot of people would be surprised
to know that schools have not thrown
offers at you.
I mean you,
you have a seriously great public profile.
Now you are respected by so many people.
You have,
you have fans and not just students.
Now you have former students,
but you have fans that would love to
sign up for courses that you would be
teaching and all sorts of things where I
think most people would look at this on
their face and think, wow,
what an asset this would,
this guy would be not only
intellectually but PR wise and all that.
That's not where we're at. It's
absolutely not. And it, uh,
it does say something and I'm,
I'm an outsider to whatever discussions
it is that result in nothing of that
sort coming our way, but
it is conspicuous. Um,
so you asked what it's, what
it's like, um, you know,
I'm having a,
a,
a very unusual experience
in life and you know, my,
my life was great before any of
this happened. It's great now.
Um,
the lack of security is
frightening when I stare at it,
you know, Heather and I have
two kids and if we didn't,
we would be in a different
position. We could take, uh,
risks and we could afford to go
through, you know, years of austerity.
But as it is,
we have responsibilities and you know,
our kids didn't sign up for this.
Hmm.
Um,
so I mean they would've let you
saying they didn't get that gene.
What are you telling me? Oh no,
they're bored. But yes. Yeah,
it's our responsibility to protect
them. And so, you know, the,
the whole thing has been,
uh,
frightening from the point of view of
what it means for the future because
literally,
I don't know,
it seems like things are headed
along a path in which, you know,
the settlement that you mentioned is
a tiny fraction of what we would have
earned over the rest of our
careers. And of course, green,
a huge amount of it was burned
up paying lawyers and, uh,
taxes, you know, you get
all that money in one chunk.
So we got about two years of buffer
money, uh, from that, but it wasn't,
it wasn't like we got bought out. We, uh,
we could have in a state
that had punitive damages,
we likely could have one,
uh,
something much more like 4 million bucks
for the amount of income that we would
have earned over the rest of our careers.
And, and why did you guys not go that
route? Because I think a lot of people,
when they saw the number,
I remember when I saw the number,
I think I just saw an article
or something and I was like,
Whoa, Whoa, whoa. Why so low?
Because Washington was one of 11
states without punitive damages.
It's that sense.
Oh, I thought you said that Washington
did have punitive damages. Oh,
I just misheard you. Okay. So
that, that uh, that caused us
to, uh, effectively cut
our losses and decide that
there was nothing to be done.
We did the best we could with evergreen
and cutting our ties with them at the
point that they made
it clear. I mean, they,
they behaved atrociously in
negotiations for one thing.
They dragged their heels.
They wouldn't sit down with us until we
were already back on contract for the
next year, fully. Assuming that we
would be going back into a classroom,
but what would it be like to walk
onto a campus that is, you know,
paying a PR firm to demonize you.
Right. What would that be like?
And we would have done it, but they, uh,
they insulted us in negotiations. They
offered us panic buttons. Right. As if,
so panic buttons in the
room. Literally. Yeah. Like,
as if the problem was that
we were panicking, um,
rather than that they had,
you know,
they could have at least they offered
you a counter baseball bat. Right.
Wouldn't that have been nice?
Right. Something. Um, but
they didn't, and, you know,
hobbling the police, the, the whole thing
was a fiasco. So we cut our losses. We've,
we've moved, we moved to Portland,
uh, which is wonderful. Um,
I know that's in some ways,
not interpretation, but
it is a marvelous place.
The more progressive place.
Uh, it does seem that we have,
whether you're a glutton for punishment
on to the belly of the beast. Um, but I,
you know, the beauty of
Portland, you know, there's a
beauty in, there's a tragedy.
There is this,
uh,
equity and inclusion thing and it seems
to go up to the mayor's office who
happens to also frighteningly in a
parallel to evergreen be the police
commissioner so he can,
uh,
stand down the police and,
and has done so in some circumstances,
all that video from a couple of weeks
ago with Antifa basically running traffic
in the middle of Portland.
I mean it's,
it's unfathomable that that's happening
in the streets of the United States
city. Right, right. It is. They
are flirting with the same, I mean,
it is the same story as
evergreen, except, um,
this is a major American city.
You know, to have a college, uh,
play games with literal anarchy is
dangerous enough to have a city doing it.
Uh, I shutter to think you
didn't want to think about Texas.
I really on this tour,
I got to tell you a San Antonio,
I think you'd have a field day over
there. Well, but here's the thing.
The other part of liberalism
is also true in Portland.
So I never encounter,
uh,
the Antifa madness and the mayor and his,
confusion. You know, it's like
the mayor of your town. You never,
you never run into it. What
I do run into, he's a clean,
uh, functional city. People
as far as I can tell,
are very decent to each
other. Um, you know, uh,
they make provisions for cyclists
to commute around the place.
So I think in some sense,
Portland is,
it shows exactly the conflict between
the left better instincts in its worst
instincts. And, uh,
I hope that it will come around to the
kind of enlightened progressivism that
used to exist rather than
the naive progressivism that
seems to have taken over
[inaudible].